dans l'espionnage vous avez les paranos
et les morts
quatre axes et qu'il commande vient ton
expliquer ce qu'on apprend finalement
ans d'école d'espionnage mon métier on
en parle à son mari sa femme ou ses
encours sont les techniques de
manipulation et quels sont les gadgets
qu'on utilise comment résiste ton à la
torture c'est lui c'est que j'espère que
vous allez bien après françois hollande
il ya quelques semaines sur la fonction
de président de la république dans cette
vidéo on va tenter de répondre aux
questions que tout le monde se pose sur
le métier d'espion et pour tenter de
mieux comprendre on est allé rencontrer
deux ex espion lula travaillé pour la
cia l'agencé de renseignement la plus
connue des états unis l'autre a
travaillé pour le kgb le service de
renseignement soviétique de temps de
l'urss vous allez le voir certaines de
leurs réponses à mes questions sont
surprenantes
je leur ai donné la candidature de ma
fiancée ils m'ont dit non parfois
c'était même froideur 2 vous avez le
droit de commettre n'importe quel crime
donc une nouvelle vidéo sur notre
nouvelle chaîne ici mais s'il vous plaît
pensez à vous abonner pour nous soutenir
et pour ne pas louper les suivantes
on donne un peu de contexte vous êtes né
en avril 1961 à moscou de vous intégrer
ensuite l'institut du drapeau rouge du
kgb c'est ça une école d'espionnage
plusieurs mois ce cas la vingtaine
l'inter comme ça une école d'espionnage
est-ce que des gestes un choix de votre
part non c'est pas un choix c'est jamais
un choix d'ailleurs des l'espionnage de
calais le kgb de n'aime pas du tout les
gens qui commencent à rêver comme ça
devenir des espions et de partir à
l'étranger non non c'est lui qui choisit
ses candidats c'est lui qui maintenant l
enquête c'est lui qui vous contacter
guillaume propose vous pouvez accepter
au pas dans mon cas effectivement vous
avez raison ça s'est passé un peu d'une
manière fort c'est quand je vais rentrer
en guillemot on m'a donné à apprendre le
français à partir de zéro et je suis
devenu tellement francophile que j'ai eu
une superbe idée de participer encore
qu'on linguistique de radio france
internationale donc depuis mon lieu
d'habitation qui était la silicon valley
soviétique donc une ville fermée dans
laquelle les étrangers n'avaient pas le
droit d'entrer j'ai envoyé un télégramme
à paris pour participer à ce concours
linguistique et bien évidemment j'ai été
pourchassés par lequel j b en fait ils
m'ont assez rapidement trouver et suite
à ça ils m'ont proposé de rentrer dans
les rangs
d'ici à ce
qu'ils
veulent
richard
hill pour maîtriser la langue étrangère
donc ça c'est la première chose deuxième
chose il faut comprendre
la problématique internationale parce
que vous avez une source et qui vous
apportent document vous devez quand même
jugé un tout petit peu si vous balade et
après il ya les matières particulière
donc déjà psychologie opérationnel parce
que l'espionnage il faut écouter les
gens et il faut inciter les gens à
trahir leur pays et à vous donner les
secrets donc pour ça on vous apprend à
étudier les gens allaient à les lire à
lire sur leur façon d'être à comprendre
leurs motivations je voudrais au nom
prénom profession numéro de portable je
vous donne un quart d'heure et après les
matières techniques technique aussi
parce qu'on utilise aussi la gamme jet
tours de gadgets vous savez tout au tout
les quasiment tous les gadgets qui a qui
sont montrés plus ou moins dans james
bond nous avions par exemple les micros
laser qui pouvait lire à part la
vibration des fenêtres votre voix aux
produits des ondes et ses hôtes font
vivre est finalement toutes les surfaces
plates qui sont autour de vous dont les
fenêtres et avec un laser on peut capter
ces célébrations et on peut lire en fête
la conversation qui se passe derrière ce
qui fait que maintenant et dans les
endroits qui sont insensibles donc les
services de sécurité équipes ses
fenêtres da contre vibrateur donc en
fête et produisent des vibrations
artificielle qui brouille toutes les
conversations qui sont qui sont dedans
sinon il ya aussi par exemple il ya un
gadget qui est assez intéressant nos
services techniques ont développé par
exemple un émetteur qui pouvaient
transmettre en une fraction de seconde
un énorme volume de données vous passiez
par exemple devant un tel bâtiment où il
y avait un récepteur et en une seconde
tout les données téléchargées
merrick numérique
pendant vos études vous tombez amoureux
et vous souhaiter à ce moment là après
vous marier mais le kgb vous dis non
est-ce que nous expliquer pourquoi il y
aurait donné la candidature de ma
fiancée et ils m'ont dit non et en
réalité avec des années maintenant
maintenant maintenant je le sais que
c'était un test mais c'est un test non
pas pour pourrait la condamner théo des
blindés étaient bonnes il voulait savoir
s'il était capable de faire le choix
entre l'amour et les services
si tu andropov les premières trois
semaines c'est un stage commando et ils
nous font sauter en parachute et là yaya
il ya par exemple sur 80 personnes de
notre promotion il ya eu deux personnes
qui n'ont pas pu
surmonter leur peur en fait de se jeter
dans le vide de l'avion donc éliminés
mais éliminé pas physiquement
[Musique]
c'est une vie de rêve quand même c'est
ça aussi peut-être quelque chose de réel
par rapport à james bond parce que j ce
bond et passe beaucoup de temps avec
champagne à la main même si on couche
pas avec toutes les belles filles qui a
qui passent mais même si on fait pas les
cours sont en voiture mais en fait les
rangs de diplomatique les réceptions
diplomatique ça c'est donc
costume-cravate belle vie les dîners les
déjeuners les réceptions ça ça existe
rennes est justement donc même question
pour bureaux des légendes qu'est ce qui
selon vous est réaliste qu est ce qui
l'est moins dans
ce qui n'est pas réaliste du tout c'est
déjà l'organisation de leur entrée dans
le bureau d les jantes et vous voyez 30
écrans avec le logo très très beau logo
de la dgse est bien évidemment ça
n'existe pas en open space dans tout
même la cia verte et bleue oui faut pas
déconner parce que nous par exemple nous
on a on avait des bureaux on était à
deux dans les bureaux on avait des
dossiers mais bien évidemment la
personne qui était en face de moi vous
savez jamais quels dossiers traités
et lui il savait quel de sujets traités
l'habitude on vous fabrique une légende
ça veut dire on vous promet à nouveau
non on vous fabrique les documents et là
la plupart du temps ça doit ça doit être
de nationalité soit du pays soit du pays
amis de deux pays dans lequel vous
faites de cionet ça veut dire aux états
unis par exemple on pourra vous faut
construire une légende d'un anglais dans
français d'un canadien d'un mexicain
d'un allemand mais pas de polonais de
2000 gare de soviétiques et c'est pour
moi c'était une exception parce que je
suis je suis venue des jeux c'est
tellement connu que c'était pas la peine
de me construire une nouvelle légende et
je suis venu sous mon propre nom mais
c'était une exception à partir de 82
quand j'étais encore étudiant on m'a
proposé de travailler pour la télévision
et donc je participer à des émissions de
télévision sur le français en français
j'ai participé dans ses émissions
pendant 14 ans donc avant le kgb pendant
lequel j b et après le kgb dans un rôle
de journaliste d'engins dans un rôle de
journalisme est un vrai rôle ça veut
dire que je ne j'ai été journaliste ça
veut dire j'avais mon émission où
j'avais ma tronche qui paraissait à la
télé finalement ils ont compris que
c'était la meilleure des couvertures
j'ai téléphoné au jeu je suis
journaliste bonjour je voudrais faire
une interview bas ils sont contents bon
bah y'a hugo qui a qui m'a vite on
commence à bavarder et ça se trouve que
votre votre père et des attaques aux
diplomates ou votre mère et était alors
et une haute responsable au ministère de
la défense boubou mais voilà j'ai
commencé pour voir s'il n'y a pas des
espions de mon équipe de journalistes
[Musique]
on n'a pas peur parce qu'on est protégé
par l'état ça veut dire que l'état quand
même j'avais traité bien que vous avez
le droit de commettre n'importe quel
crime vous avez un état derrière vous un
service énorme et un état derrière vous
donc il fera tout pour vous sortir du
tout donc ça vous donne une tranquillité
d'esprit tout se gère vous vous dites
parano j'ai l'habitude de répondre dans
l'espionnage vous avez les paranos et
les morts si vous voulez pas être mort
il faut devenir part annoncé lorsque
vous perdez la peur c'est là où vous
risquez le plus parce qu'il ya plus le
mécanisme n'ya plus le la petite
sonnerie qui va me dire oh là là tu
t'attends tu as dépassé les bornes
et si des
caractéristiques
on nous dit que c'est une éventualité
qui peut arriver or on nous rassure
aussi que ça arrive très rarement il ça
arrive dans certains pays seulement en
revanche il nous expliquait que de toute
façon si ça vous arrive vous voir
raconter parce que toute façon quelqu'un
qui vous torture tant qu'on n'avait pas
raconter tout ce que vous avez à
raconter et vous lâchera pas donc toute
façon faut pas c'est pas la peine de
jouer au héros c'est pas la peine de
dire non je vous dirai jamais rien
déjà comprendre la personne ça veut dire
qu'il faut déjà avoir la connaissance de
bavarder avec la personne comprendre ce
qui la motive question ses peurs qui
sont ses préférences on a trop tendance
à dire par exemple on va le faire
chanter les avec quelqu'un et on a été
c'est la dernière chose à laquelle on
pense ça s'appelle la motivation
négative tandis que la mode la meilleure
motivation c'est la monnaie motivation
positive elle même en fait c'est ça
c'est ça ça veut dire essayer les fameux
maïs en anglais donc manier aux
compromissions et igo donc les quatre
piliers puis on peut rajouter le sexe
que si la personne est motivée
positivement d'elle-même elle fera dix
fois mieux que 6 voix contre et nié
qu'une personne mais be
sometimes européenne ue même source
il
était
persuadé que le métier d'espion est en
train de mourir on n'aura plus besoin
d'un espion dans le sens classique du
terme parce que le monde est
interconnecté actuellement tellement que
finalement c'est les gars femmes qui
sont devenus les vrais espions et n'ont
même pas les états ils sont
bien évidemment tous les gens qui sont
dans les services d'espionnage vont nous
dire il raconte n'importe quoi dedans on
a beau toujours besoin de nous parce que
on poussait encore découvrir de ce
qu'elles ont fait signer